هذه الاخبار العاجله نقلا عن سي ان ان وهي
تنقل عن مسؤولين
بمقتل ثلاثه جنود امريكيين واصابه نحو 24
في هجوم على موقع للقوات الامريكيه على
حدود الاردن وسوريا كذلك تنقل سي ان ان عن
مسؤولين امريكيين
بان هذه اول مره يقتل فيها جنود امريكيون
في هجمات على م صالح امريكيه منذ بدء
الحرب على غزه معنا الان من واشنطن مراس
الجزيره فادي منصور فادي اذا كنت في
الاستماع
يعني ضعنا في صوره ما اعلنته سي ان ان
نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين تقول بان هذه هي
المره الاولى التي يعلن فيها عن مقتل جنود
امريكيين منذ بد هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه
على القطاع ماذا يعني ذلك وما
دلالاته
نعم ايمان لدينا تاكيد رسمي وردنا في بيان
من القياده الوسطى الان يقول انه في ال8
من يناير اي اليوم لقي ثلاثه اعضاء من
القوات عناصر من القوات الامريكيه حتفهم
واصيب 25 اخرون بجراح جراء هجوم
بمسيره الذي مسيره ضربت قاعده تابعه
للقوات الامريكيه في شمال شرق
الاردن بالقرب من الحدود مع سوريا القياده
الوسطى قالت انها لن تعلن حتى هذه اللحظه
عن اسماء الجنود القتلى عملا بسياستها
المتعلقه بابلاغ عوائل الجنود الذين
يسقطون واشارت انها سوف توفر المزيد من
المعطيات في هذا الشان وبالتالي بالفعل
منذ بدء الهجمات على القوات الامريكيه في
السا من اكتوبر في العراق وسوريا من قبل
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه او ما يسمى
بالمقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق هذه المره
الاولى الذي يقتل فيها جنود امريكيون سبق
ان اصيب عدد من الجنود الامريكيين حتى
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي كانت هناك نحو 70
اصابه معظمها اصابات طفيفه كما ابل كما
نقلنا عن مسؤولينا في البنتاجون تحديدا
اصابات دماغيه رديه كان اخرها خلال الهجوم
يوم السبت الماضي على قاعده عين الاسد في
العراق بصواريخ بالستيه ادت الى اصابه
اربعه جنود امريكيين لكن هذه المره الاولى
التي يقتل فيها جنود امريكيون فضلا عن هذه
الاصابات الواسعه 24 اصابه في العاده
المواقع والقواعد
الامريكيه مجهزه بانظمه دفاع جوي وفي بعض
الاماكن
بصواريخ حتى منظومات باتريوت وبالتالي هذا
الهجوم داخل الاردن يمثل من ناحيه
الاصابات تطور خطير للغايه مع التذكير ان
الولايات المتحده كانت شنت عدد من الغارات
داخل الاراضي السوريه تحديدا في محيط
منطقه البوكمال وايضا داخل الاراضي
العراقيه وكان اخرها الاسبوع الماضي
تحديدا ردا على القصف الذي تعرضت له قاعده
عين الاسد ضد فصائل فلس عراقيه تحديدا
كتائب حزب الله في العراق فضلا عن هجمات
ايضا ضد مواقع تابعه لحركه النجباء وايضا
عمليه ضربت وقتها وادت الى مقتل مسؤول في
حركه النجباء وهو ابو تقوى في عمليه عمليه
قصف ل سيارته في بغداد وبالتالي هذا تطور
خطير هناك تاكيد رسمي ونحن نحاول ان نحصل
على مع معطيات اضافيه حول طبيعه تفاصيل
هذا الهجوم ومن اين انطلقت هذه المسيره
سواء من الاراضي السوريا او من داخل
العراق ايمان ا الى حين الحصول على المزيد
من المعلومات يعني سي ان ان تتحدث عن
مسؤولين امريكيين هل ورد اي من اسماء
هؤلاء المسؤولين الامريكي الذين افادوا
بتلك
المعلومات فادي او يعني هل ورد اي بيان من
البنتاجون من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تؤكد
او تنفي او تتحدث عن تفاصيل هذه الهجمات
او هذا الهجوم
بالمسير ايمان لقد قرات للتو البيان
الرسمي الذي وردنا من القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه وهي القياده المسؤوله عن القوات
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط ومن ضمن نطاق
عملياتها الاردن بيان القياده الوسطى يؤكد
بشكل رسمي ان اليوم ال8 من يناير لقي
ثلاثه جنود امريكيون حتفهم بهجوم مسيره
على احدى مواقع القوات الامريكيه في شمال
شرق الاردن بالقرب من الحدود مع سوريا
فضلا عن اصابه 24 جنديا وبالتالي هناك
تاكيد رسمي من قبل القياده الوسطى في
القوات الامريكيه ايمان هو تاكيد رسمي من
قبل القياده الامريكيه الوسطى في بيان لكن
هل هناك اي اي تخطيط لعقد اي مؤتمر صحفي
يتم فيه الحديث عن المزيد من تلك التفاصيل
فادي كما يجري كما هي العاده في واشنطن
ننوه فقط الى ان بايدن يقول الهجوم على
قواتنا والذي اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه عسكريين
نفذته جماعه او جماعات متشدده مدعومه من
ايران تعمل بسوريا والعراق وايضا نذكر بان
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه تتحدث عن مقتل
او تؤكد مقتل ثلاثه جنود واصابه 25 اخرين
في هجوم بطائره مسيره استهدف قاعده في
شمال شرق الاردن وكان قد ورد قبل ذلك هذه
الانباء عبر سي ان ان نقلا عن مسؤول
امريكي بان هذه هي المره الاولى التي يتم
فيها مقتل جنود
امريكيين على الحدود بالاردن قرب حدود
سوريا اعود لك فادي منصور عاده يعني ما
يجري الحديث من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه عن التفاصيل من خلال مؤتمرات
صحفيه هل يتوقع او هل هو مبرمج ان يتم
الحديث عن المزيد من التفاصيل عن هذا
الحادث لنعود فقط لما نوهت به في بيان
الرئيس بايدن اشار الى ان الهجوم وقع ليله
امس ربما هو يشير الى توقيت منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بخلاف بيان القياده الوسطى الت
الذي قال ان الهجوم وقع في ال8 واشار الى
ان الهجوم الذي اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه جنود
امريكيين حصل بطائره مسيره على موقعهم في
شمال شرق الاردن بالقرب من الحدود السوريه
البارز في بيان الرئيس بايدن انه في الوقت
الذي تواصل فيه الاداره جمع المعطيات
والحقائق حول هذا الهجوم قال نحن نعلم ان
هذا هجوم شنته ميليشيات راديكاليه مدعومه
من ايران تعمل في العراق وسوريا وبالتالي
الرئيس بايدن يتهم رسميا ما وصفها
بالميليشيات
الراديكاليه المدعومه من ايران التي تعمل
من العراق وسوريا
واضاف ان هؤلاء الجنود الامريكيين عمليا
ضحوا في
حياتهم احاول ان نحصل اذا قال اي شيء فيما
يتعلق باي رد فعل قال ان الاداره
الامريكيه ومع العائلات سوف تظل وفيه
لذكرى هؤلاء الجنود وسوف نواصل عمليا
التزامهم لمحاربه الارهابيين ولا ينبغي ان
يكون لديكم اي شك سوف نحمل جميع المسؤولين
عن هذا
الهجوم المسؤوليه و
المحاسبه في وقت ومكان نقوم باختياره
وبالتالي الرئيس بايدن عمليا يؤكد هذا
الهجوم يؤكد مقتل ثلاثه جنود امريكيين
يحمل ما وصفها بالميليشيات
ال الراديكاليه المدعومه من قبل
ايران في العراق وسوريا المسؤوليه عن هذا
الهجوم يشير الى ان الاداره تواصل جمع
المعطيات حول كيفيه حصول الهجوم ولكنه
يؤكد انه سوف يكون هناك ر امريكي في الوقت
والزمان المناسبين ايمان ا الى حين معرفه
المزيد من التفاصيل عن هذا الهجوم وعن
توقيته و كيفيه يعني وقوف هذه الميليشيات
الراديكاليه كما اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وقوفها مدعومه من ايران كما قال
وتعمل في العراق
وسوريا الى حين معرف المزيد من التفاصيل
فقط
نذكر المشاهدين بهذه الاخبار العاجله التي
اكدتها القياده الوسطى الامريكيه مقتل
ثلاثه جنود واصابه
25 اخرين
اي في هجوم على القوات
الامريكيه بطائره مسيره شمال شرق الاردن
قرب حدود سوريا اذا وصفت فادي هذا الهجوم
بالتطور الخطير اي فيما يتعلق بهذه
الهجمات هي المره الاولى التي يقتل فيها
جنود امريكيون كذلك منذ بدء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه يعني كيف يمكن
ان يقرا هكذا هجوم بهذا التوقيت في
الولايات المتحده
برايك هناك لا شك ان هناك اسئله كثيره
تطرح على اداره بايدن خلال الفتره الماضيه
تحديدا من قبل المشرعين الامريكيين سما
المعارضين للاداره الامريكيه في صفوف
الحزب الجمهوري والسؤال الكبير المعلق فوق
هذا الاداره اذا كانت كل هذه الهجمات التي
تعرضت لها القوات الامريكيه في كل من
العراق وسوريا منذ الساب عشر من شهر
اكتوبر والتي تجاوزت 150 هجوما وادت الى
اصابه عدد من الجنود الامريكيين والاداره
تقول انها تعلم ان ايران هي التي تدعم
بالسلاح والتدريب والتمويل من تصفهم
الاداره الامريكيه بوكلاه في كل من سوريا
والعراق لماذا لا يتخذ اي اجراء ضد ايران
تحديدا الاداره الامريكيه كانت حتى ما قبل
هذا الهجوم تؤكد الى انها لا تريد التصعيد
وانها بعثت برسائل واضحه لطهران من خلال
وسطاء وبشكل مباشر بضروره الكف عن هذا
الهجمات واكدت اداره بايدن انها ستفعل كل
شيء ممكن لحمايه مصالحها وقواتها في
المنطقه وتحديدا في العراق وسوريا لكن
اليوم هناك حديث عن قتلى من الجنود
الامريكيين وهذا يعتبر عمليا حاله سابقه
في حاله من هذا النوع اداره بايدن سوف
تكون تحت ضغوط هائله للرد ليس فقط على من
وصفهم الرئيس بايدن بالميليشيات ولكن ايضا
ربما على ايران نفسها خصوصا ان اداره
بايدن وكما قال في بيانه ان الميليشيات
نحن نعلم قال ان من شن هذا الهجوم هي
ميليشيات راديكاليه مدعومه من ايران في كل
من العراق وسوريا ورغم ان الاداره تقول
انها لا تسعى الى الحرب مع ايران لكن هذا
يمثل منعطف خطير وبالتالي سوف يكون الرئيس
بايدن مطالب برد مختلف هذه المره يعني في
اطار الحديث عن هذه الردود المختلفه فقط
ننوه فادي الى ان البنتاغون قال الان ما
تعرضت له قواتنا في الاردن هو تصعيد خطير
اذا هذا هو اخر الاخبار العاجله تصريح
وموقف من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البنتاغون تقول ما تعرضت له قواتنا في
الاردن تصعيد خطير اذا فادي ماذا يمكن ان
يكون من خيارات امام الولايات المتحده وقد
اكد الرئيس بايدن بانه سيحاسب كل
المسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف
قواتنا كما قال في الوقت المناسب
وبالطريقه التي نختارها كيف نفهم مثل هذا
التصريح نعم هو يشبه التصريحات السابقه
التي عمليا ادلى بها المسؤولون الامريكيون
ولكن كنا نتحدث عن احداث ادت الى اصابات
في صفوف القوات الامريكيه
وبحسب المسؤولين في البنتاغون هذه
الاصابات التي تجاوزت الس اصابه ظلت
اصابات طفيفه ذكر ان عمليات القصف
الامريكي التي حدثت على سبيل المثال في
سوريا في محيط منطقه البوكمال اعلنت في
حينها الاداره والبنتاغون انها لم تستهدف
فقط من تصفهم بالميليشيات المدعومه من
ايران بل ايضا ان هذه المقرات التي تعرضت
للقصف هي مقرات تابعه ايضا للحرس الثوري
الايراني وبالتالي هذا احد المناحي الذي
قد تذهب اليه الاداره الامريكيه
اللافت انه في الوقت الذي حصل فيه هذا
الهجوم كانت هناك مقابله ولكنها مسجله مع
قائد الاركان في القوات الامريكيه الجنرال
تشارلز براون الذي قال فيها انه لا يعتقد
ان ايران تسعى للحرب مع الولايات المتحده
لكن عمليا الرئيس بايدن عندما اشار ونص في
بيان رسمي على ان المسؤول عن قتل الجنود
الامريكيين ثلاثه في حادثه غير مسبوقه منذ
بدء الهجمات على القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه في السا من اكتوبر اعتبر ان ايران
هي التي تقف وراء هذه المجموعات وهو قال
اننا سنحمل المسؤوليه ونحاسب عمليا
المسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم ايران في هذه
الصياغه وفي ادبيات الاداره الامريكيه
والبنتاغون تتحمل مسؤوليه عن كل تلك
الهجمات بما انها توفر ل هذه المجموعات
المسيرات وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ
والتدريب والمشوره واكثر من ذلك هي تعتبر
انها وكيله لايران من وكلاء ايران اي هي
تعمل باوامر ايران وتحديدا من قبل الحرس
الثوري الايراني وبالتالي هنا الخيارات
مفتوحه بشكل لا يمكن الشخص ان يحدد تحديدا
كيف ستتصرف الاداره الامريكيه دون الذهاب
الى حرب واسعه في المنطقه شكرا لك فادي
منصور ابقى معنا الان ننوه فقط الى ان
بايدن الرئيس الامريكي في بيان يقول قلب
امريكا مثقل بمقتل ثلاثه جنود امريكيين في
الهجوم على قواتنا شمال شرقي الاردن اذا
كان بايدن قد قد اكد قبل قليل مقتل هؤلاء
العسكريين الامريكيين الثلاثه بهجوم
بطائره مسيره على القوات الامريكيه شمال
شرقي الاردن قرب حدود سوريا وقد قال بان
الولايات الم المتحده ستحاسب كل المسؤولين
عن هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف القوات في
الوقت المناسب وبالطريقه التي نختارها او
تختارها الولايات المتحده الان